le sphinx de daoukro n'a jamais aussi
bien porté son nom
henri konan-bédié est loin d'être un
inconnu dans le paysage politique
ivoirien président du pays entre 1993 et
1999 il a été renversé suite à un coup
d'état militaire
en 2010 il décide de se représenter
il arrive en troisième position à
l'issue du premier tour derrière laurent
gbagbo et alassane ouattara
cinq ans plus tard en 2015 il annonce
rallier la candidature d'alassane
ouattara et ne présente pas de candidat
au parti démocratique de côte d'ivoire
à 86 ans il revient donc sur le devant
de la scène en tant que candidat du pdc
y une candidature qui nourrit la
polémique auprès de la jeunesse
ivoirienne
la passe d'achever d'un riz qu'on avait
dit à 80,6 agrément il est âgé donc je
préfère qu'il se repose enfin qu'il
présente quelqu'un d'autre qui leva
d'idées qu'il va conseiller
nous sommes laissé le pouvoir à la
jeunesse pour que vous et moi le pouvoir
une à la jeunesse parce que la
population ivoirienne est formé des
jeunes est la meilleure de la plaine où
elle est jeune et je crois que en nos
jeunes on pourrait au premier sa portée
la solution est en tout cas
non je pense que sarko n'habitez devait
laisser la place à la jeunesse
si la candidature un service dans avec
les médias après six ans vraiment c'est
pas du tout moi japon rose avoir normal
qui va c'est le blues il vaut mieux
attendre six ans qu'est-ce que vous
emportez vos auparavant l'âge limite
pour être candidat à la présidentielle
en côte d'ivoire était fixé à 75 ans une
restriction qui éliminé d'office
l'octogénaire mais en 2016 la
constitution est modifiée et l'âge
limite est levée la cena dispositions
constitutionnelles relativement à la
conditionnalité de large pour être
président de la république fixe elle
atteint l'âge limite à 75 ans est
évidemment monsieur laurent gbagbo
monsieur alassane ouattra et messieurs
l'idée d'un telle posture cv line acte à
briguer la présidence de la république
la réforme est intervenue la gelée mix a
été sautée aujourd'hui nous sommes dans
un système de plus en plus libérale
relativement à cette conditionnalité
donc toute personne en côte d'ivoire
ayant plus de 35 ans peut valablement
vouloir briguer la présidence de la
république en âge qui ne fait en tout
cas pas débat au sein du pdc y comme en
témoigne jean louis billon secrétaire
exécutif du parti vous savez le
président bédié c'est vrai il a un
certain âge nous l'appelons le vieux
mais il est le seul vieux dans l'équipe
l'équipe même et je ne voudrais que la
moyenne d'âge des cadres un pdc y est
plus jeune que celle des autres partis
aujourd'hui l'âge du président bédié
c'est vrai est un âge avancé il a une
expérience il a connu plusieurs crises
dans le pays et il a su s'entourer de
cadres jeunes dynamiques et compétents
c'est surtout cela qui le voit les les
électeurs vers en une équipe en face
d'eux ils verront des jeunes débattre
ils verront des compétences diverses et
variées en face d'eux et c'est ça le
plus important
henri konan-bédié a donc désormais
quatre mois de campagne électorale
devant lui pour tenter de convaincre le
peuple ivoirien qui se rendra aux urnes
le 31 octobre prochain